so let's let's talk about the Phaedo in
general first it's a dialogue but it's a
dialogue inside a dialogue so that
presents certain certain problems in
your reading it doesn't what's the top
level dialogue who's that between and
what is it happening yeah they know and
yeah eka crosses we got this guy's fate
oh there's a young man and he's not
actually Athenian and then we have a
project yeah an epic project wasn't
there when Socrates died so he says hey
don't you know were you there can you
tell me about it
and Fela says yeah I remember the whole
thing I'll tell you the story
and so now fado is going to tell the
story about what took place in the past
and we know that that first fatal affair
right and I'm not going to ask you you
know a total number of people who were
there or anything like that because most
of them don't talk who was there that
actually talked and said anything
interesting or important obviously one
guy right Debbie died Gerry end up in
sciocracy threat and here is a portion
where Socrates and fado talk to each
other they'll actually be the first
single look at who else who are some of
the other important characters
there's one who's like kind of
preoccupied with details and stuff like
we're inside yeah Crudup
right yeah Brenda Socrates Socrates
actually ends by saying hey I forgot to
make this sacrifice can you take care of
that credo takes away Socrates wife when
she's crying turns out some of the other
guys cry too
you know including Apollodorus or like
burst into tears but that's all we hear
about Apollodorus who else to be here
about who else talks in this yeah yeah
okay city else and he's got a friend
who's from the same city
don't worry about mispronouncing just
blurt it up seven eighths is fine
kay bakes I've heard it love pronounced
a whole bunch of different ways I think
in the Greek it's it's something like a
base vegans I said Acer whatever you
like so these two guys are foreigners I
think it's two M's they're from the city
of Thebes which is further north and
theta was actually from another city -
he was a originally a prisoner of war
and sold into slavery and some of
socrates friends ransomed him some bad
stuff happened to him while you as well
as a slave as well and he sort of
attached himself to socrates he's from
Ellis if I remember right credo is
actually from the north side a happens
one of the one of the the Deeb's
and these guys are gonna have a
conversation and so fado is narrating
this conversation - that your projects
and their by Plato is in the
the conversation to you and me total
labor and this is sort of a narrative
device it has a little wrinkle to it it
does make it a little bit tough
sometimes to figure out exactly who's
saying what as you get to know the
characters and you get to know what it
is that they stand for it's a little bit
easier to tell but on the first reading
and perhaps a little bit difficult isn't
it so let's start with something that's
not actually at the start of the
dialogue let's start with something
where Socrates is actually talking with
beta there is an interesting discussion
that goes on between Socrates and fado
and it has to do with fate on Socrates
has to do with something that he calls
miss Lotus or distrust of arguments
distrust or bees and he says that this
is like missing Anthropy what does
misanthropy if somebody is a misanthrope
it's not a word we use a lot we have a
whole bunch of other words that you
could probably you know call them line
somebody who hates other people we have
a word that we use for that we usually
focus on the behavior something hates
other people like doesn't just hate a
few other people people in general we
focus on the behavior so what we call a
person well is there a critic they're
there like a critic all the way across
the board so yeah I suppose I suppose
certain kinds of critics sometimes we
say cynics in
but as well somebody's cynical but think
about behavior again jerks right a lot
of jerks are jerks because they think
everybody's a jerk too so I'm going to
act like a jerk myself any other words
we use for people I think you could
probably think of something won't fit up
but what's that oh yeah okay yeah I was
thinking it like words that way to put
on chalkboard because they're you know
first words but we have a whole stock of
these sort of things right and you've
experienced these kind of people
how do people end up being like that
that's what Socrates starts with the
asking date of about and this is a
pretty interesting what do you what he
says he says I think about people who
become misanthropic did they originally
start out by just liking other people
the answer is no how did they originally
start out these people who become
cynical or critics well it starts out
and put this over here starts but I
being too trusting uncritical yeah they
try to see the best in everybody a lot
of times pessimist service discipline an
optimist they trust everybody whether
they should or not they lack good
judgment they lack you know criticism
isn't necessarily bad being a critic
means being a good judge they lack an
understanding of human nature if you had
a good understanding of human nature the
way Socrates is talking about it how
would you see people in general
there's some people who are very good
right some people who are very bad is
that that is that it everybody is either
good or bad yeah there's a big gray zone
and the gray zone is gray just sort of
like it's not because it's you know a
new color or something like that gray is
a mixture of black and white right the
people who are in the middle are a
mixture of good and bad they're good in
this way they're bad in this way you can
trust them in this this context don't
trust them in this context you know
there are even some bad people you can
trust in certain contexts you know
somebody's got a gambling problem don't
give them your credit card but you might
you know be able to be friends with them
in some other respect somebody's got a
drinking problem don't want them having
a drink because as soon as you do it's
downhill but you know maybe you could do
something like go on a road trip with
them provide you don't let them have any
alcohol
do they be a good driver
right there's a lot of ways in which
people can be good and bad at the same
time and the the person who is too
trusting what do they do they they build
people up to be much better than they
are and then what's the natural result
maybe some of you have gone through that
to the point all right have you guys
experienced this with your your views on
your friends family never been let down
if you've been let down it's in part
because they did something that they
weren't supposed to do but it's also in
part because you had an unrealistic
understanding of who they were could be
partly their fault could be that they
trapped they they snowed you they
convinced you that there is somebody who
they weren't there are some cases where
you're not responsible for that there's
a lot of cases where we're really
responsible for getting things wrong you
know I had a friend when I was working
restaurants years and years ago I was
when I was your age he and he was the
assistant manager of the restaurant and
he had a girlfriend who is in college at
the time he was putting her through
college and all of us could like no see
that as soon as she finished college he
was paying for the whole thing as soon
as she finished college that she was
gone and we told him that he's like nah
we're getting married love each other
and you know she was kind of lovely wmm
but you know if he'd paid attention he
could see through that and wasn't just
like me and a few friends were saying
this everybody says what do you think
happened sure enough she graduated and
within a month she's gone
and what do you think happened the guy
she was sad and I went beyond being sad
yeah and cynical about it
very good yeah everything at that point
all women became you know the enemy and
he also started stealing from the
business because he figured out it
people are bad
I may as well be bad like them and he
got caught in are going to prison not
for too long you know even going for a
little while bad thing and it makes it
tough for you later on and if you had a
more realistic understanding of this
person that he was dealing with you
might not have been so disappointed now
can this apply to discussions about
things kind of supply to our thoughts or
ideas our ideologies have you ever known
a person who
sort of a conversion to some sort of way
of life that had some intellectual
component to it they you know they read
a self-help book and now their whole
life is on track or they embraced some
sort of ideology yeah
I'm being serious back yeah I could be a
good example particularly if you're a
principled vegetarian you can articulate
it yeah there's a difference between
vegetarian and vegan vegans Countdown
vegetarians because we're not people
fully with the program and yeah you know
if you ask a vegan why are you a vegan
they often have a lot to say about that
now unfortunately a lot of what they
have to say turns out to not be true
there's good is healthier in some
respects but not always for the reasons
that they induce and a lot of other
stuff that goes into that and if you
know if you go into something like that
you go into some sort of movement and
you embrace all the ideas and then you
find out no it's not exactly as you
thought that's sort of like having that
friend who lets you down this and that
it happens over and over again do you
know any people who go from my side of
ideas to set of ideas to set of ideas
and this was the total truth over here
before and I totally had it figured out
and then that crashes and then they go
to another one over here and that
crashes and they just keep jumping from
one to one where do you think they're
headed eventually if it's like this to
being cynical it's all BS none of it
there are a lot of people who end up
like that
you you won't end up like that sakis is
putting out if you actually use
dialectic if you test arguments when
people give you a set of ideas you say
why don't know is this really true let
me think about this can I ask you a few
questions and then you see how they
respond to the questions you know if
their response to the question is shut
up and just you know do the party line
there's probably something hinky going
out there right if they can actually
respond and explain it to you then maybe
it makes sense and this this applies to
a lot of different things so this could
also even apply to reading Plato if what
you expect out of Plato is something
that's going to be like sparknotes and
you know just a little move it's all
going to make perfect sense you're going
to be really disappointed aren't you
because is it like that now you know
right well the question you have to ask
yourself is what what do I actually
expect to get out of this with any sort
of intellectual object or artifact that
you're going to approach what am I
supposed to get out of this what can a
person get out of this will you get the
same out of reading some type of
horoscopes as you will offer your theta
probably not so you know if you're
expecting the same thing on both of them
you're probably going to be disappointed
in one for one reason and one for the
other reason you don't want to get
disappointed like that if you found
yourself already sort of on that track
you can correct that the way to correct
that is what do you think so if having a
good understanding of human nature the
way people really are was the antidote
us what would be the case would be
something like that for intellectual
life what is it you guys are doing here
in college yeah
learning what though that's your other
attract
yeah I think it's more so quick learning
to learning to learn but it's watch
again ladies Marco yeah you know I mean
there are some cases where somebody can
just give you information that's all you
want right no what time is a meeting
today we don't do any reading a dialogue
to figure that out just tell me the time
6:30 okay I'll be there with things that
matter more yeah you have to have to be
open to investing the time not expecting
that the first time you read it it's
going to make total sense
are there any you know here's another
thing to think about are there any
contradictions in Plato's views somebody
pointed some of these out at least what
you thought were contradictions in his
notion about the doctrine of
recollection in here your assignments
some very good papers too by the way and
in that batch now when there's a
contradiction you got to ask yourself
this is it a real contradiction did I
fully understand what I'm looking at or
am I reading a contradiction there
that's not actually there a lot of
people say all contradiction and I'm not
forget this I this this is stuff is
worthless I'm going to get rid of it I'm
never going to spend any time with it
that's sort of like saying well that one
friend you know let me down at one time
and I'm not even sure if they actually
let me down or not but I'm going to
treat it like that if I'm going to talk
to them again that's not the way you
want to behave towards towards a fork or
set of ideas you want to actually think
it through if you had a friend of your
friend let you down what would you do
with your friend you could just say I'm
done with you and if your friend lets
you down over and over again probably
you to do that right if Plato turns out
to be just chock-full of contradictions
you know after reading through five
times maybe get rid of the Plato but if
you have a friend and your friend
generally is a good
you know person but they did let you
down what would you do with your friend
just ignore it and like you know fume
and might take it out of them later
no don't silly explain till we get
involved with this uh next time you guys
meet seriously yeah there's that there's
that side what else would you do give
them less opportunities like now I
suppose there's one other thing you
could do that would like start fixing
things between the two of you would
involve me asking
ask question what would happen don't you
know you know you tie these things in
together don't you know that you let me
down by doing this and then you know
they might give the answer I don't care
tough tough for you no no definitely
closed off those opportunities maybe
they don't realize that they let you
down or maybe there's you know maybe
they would explain something to you like
oh yeah actually you didn't let me down
it's the same way with approaching texts
you want to do that in this life so this
metaphor that Socrates has here about
the difference or the similarities are
between miss lodges of the word he made
up and misanthropic it's something that
I think is useful for when you when
you're when you're reading Plato or
reading any of the other people that
we're going to cover this semester so
that's kind of a nice thing for setting
the stage what else is this dialog about
it's not just about you know just load
ISM map that came about halfway through
the dialog what are some of the big
themes big picture things this dialog
I'm not saying that there's many big
feet oh the first on design and that's
what means okay yeah means that's a big
part of this I mean the guy is going to
die by the end of the dialogue so
presumably he's got that his mind you
know everybody else does too girl crying
upset what else what else came up
yeah very good
and what else there's another theory
that comes up here too but we'll get
into that when we talk about
recollection
unless you want forms right yeah what
else what are some other things that
happen yeah
yeah what about is it a mortal or very
good is it real eight more it's a big
question when you're gonna die is that I
may not matter right now but when you
know what you're going to die doesn't
suddenly you know or your friend is
going to die suddenly you know these
questions press upon I think probably a
quite a few of it to do a lot of you
come from big families you've
experienced some deaths in their
families right and that's often when
these questions weirded someone zoko
than are they still there in any
meaningful way that's something we care
about anything else that that came up
yeah wisdom yeah what is any other
things things coming out of their office
yeah and that has to do with these
arguments there's going to be some
arguments made about the immortality of
the soul and I'm actually going to put
those will offer for next class session
because they're kind of complicated and
they involve a lot of metaphysics and
all that so we're going to skirt around
those you know those are the bulk of the
dialogue and we're going to talk about
these other things like the meaning of
death certain things about the soul the
theory of recollection of the theory of
forms so let me ask you which would you
like first
you can pick between meaning of death
soul the body or the theory of
recollection and period forms we're
going to evolve which would be like the
first one okay start with the the big
thing right so they're asking Socrates
wide where's you bothered by the fact
that you're going to die I mean it's bad
nothing that year your city is executing
you for no good reason but aren't you by
yourself as an individual afraid of the
fact that you're going to die and so
actually says no I'm you know pretty
happy I'm looking forward to it and I
saw something in here that's that's a
little strange
waspy is a preparation
for doubt
so that's kind of downer isn't it you
take an intro to philosophy class and
then you know third main class session
if somebody's telling you yeah what are
we what are we doing here learning how
to dialogue exactly what you wanted to
sign up for at eight o'clock and more
thinking about that well you know what
does he mean by death that's one of the
things that we got to wrap our heads
around right there what does it mean for
for Plato there's some assumptions built
into this oh yeah that is so very good
so we have two parts to the human being
as we are here as Socrates was the soul
and the body and this is a pretty
traditional conception of the human
being
and not everybody buys this not
everybody actually bought it that's mine
that there's no something spiritual or
you know non-violently that continues
that's separable from the body a lot of
people do believe this sort of thing and
if you do believe this sort of thing
then there's going to be some sort of
major distinction between the two of
these and bodies you know what does
death mean for the body the body ceases
to be a living body ceases to do certain
things and then what happens to the
corpse
there's not as a bunch of bones and meat
you know other organs and stuff like
that what happens to it but we don't
know about this too much because we
don't have a lot of contact with with
dead people being along to keep them
keep anything
make up on that sort of weird things
think about roadkill right
you give all experience roadkill deer
you know get hit by a semi what happens
to that that I mean you know it dies
what happens to their body wrong yeah
rots that's the process of decomposition
I think they gave me a cycle
very good what is that cycle involve the
rotting is part of that anything else
happened to crows come along yeah
driving and decomposing are we now know
this other things acting upon that you
know usually what's up it's consumed
yeah it's consumed by other organisms
it's broken down into its basic
components and then it's turning to
other bodies is that this is the process
of life and death things eat each other
with the exception of plants that eat
dirt air a few plants you know the face
but everything else beats something else
all the animals eat something fungi eat
something
so the body ceases to be what about the
soul what is death from the perspective
of the soul it's actually being free of
the body isn't it now the question that
would be is that a good thing or a bad
thing that really depends on your
perspective doesn't it and so if
philosophy is preparation for death
philosophies preparation for this event
for the body and soul are going to go
their separate ways
and the body is going to lose with
whatever it had whatever good looks
you've got you know when you died you're
going to retain them for a little while
then they're going to be go on break
your hands go on because your dad health
of course
right that's a good of body that's not
there what is your soul Keith that's a
good question what does your soul
actually retain yeah very good
Socrates says it retains its knowledge
and it retains one of the thing he calls
its discipline and this would be the
moral condition so you know were you a
greedy person in life well you're going
to be a greedy person after your body
and soul separate here's the greed is
going to be in your soul greed is not
really something that you do you know
that that's part of your body it's
something you do through your body you
go and take stuff down because you're a
thief or you know take more than your
fair share but it's really your soul
that's driving it and that that habit
the three does in your soul
what if you're a generous person you
take that with you too if you're a
courageous person you take that if your
cowardly person so everything that you
you you know learned everything that
you've accumulated in in who you are and
your personality you know good soul
trips you up this theological language
just think personality the personality
somehow survive enter death you keep
that with you so philosophy is training
to pay attention to the difference
between these two and trying to train
this part of who you are so that when
you shed the husk you've got good stuff
left behind are there some people who
you know page you know attention to the
body and don't attend to the soul they
don't have what doctors called care of
the soul do you think of any people like
like that we make reality shows
because they're photogenic usually
good-looking bodies yeah quite a few
celebrities you know you wouldn't you
really wouldn't want to be stuck in
eternity with them you know they're
good-looking they might you know be able
to get you into a lot of parties and
they're kind of fun for a while those
reasons why they have to pay people to
hang around they're really great people
people wanting swag to do so so you know
there's a choice here that everybody has
to face not just the philosopher where
are you going to put your attention
socrates talks about things in terms of
like pleasures desires
do you have bodily desires that you go
she didn't your body debt just you know
some of them are like eating and
drinking better sight of that but you're
not going to survive what are other
bodily desires that you have I may
usually time to be able to say with
pleasures or pains trying to have
pleasures or avoid certain pains what do
you like what are you doing I like
drinking coffee parks are like the
stimulant effect and parks I like the
taste
that's a bodily pleasure if I don't get
it after about two days I have terrible
headaches like so many addict
the right word for it not making the
arrow or something like that just coffee
and I'm trying to avoid gains for other
pleasures of pain
web designers for their bottle just
bottled else do we want
it drives us yeah sweet yeah it's a big
one especially for you students you get
it
chronic we sleep-deprived one reason why
you're chronically sleep-deprived is
because because of another set of
pleasures that you seek out I'm not just
talking about sex I mean that's one
stimulation like getting what's what's
going on over there let me go watch this
show they were to turn on the TV and
you're like I'm going to watch one show
and then I'm going to turn it off and we
get to work and get to sleep on times
because I got this 8 o'clock class and
then you know three three episodes
reading like what happened well that's
you know those are bodily pleasures you
enjoy looking at things don't you enjoy
hearing music is a bodily pleasure taste
there's lots of things Socrates in this
dialogue is very pessimistic about them
he actually calls those nails in the
coffin of the soul which is the body the
body is like a coffin that the soul is
imprisoned in and the soul bears the
traces of the things of our body so if
we spend all of our time looking at you
know physical pleasures and desiring
those and chasing after those what's
going to happen to us we're going to
have that kind of soul and that soul is
going to be created those kinds of
pleasures and what's going to happen
when it's out of the body can it can it
enjoy those pleasures it's gonna be very
unhappy yeah are there other other
pleasures that you can enjoy just with
your your soul are there other things
that are good that you desire in life
that are nothing let's say just more of
your soul maybe you use your body to do
them what about reading
how many enjoyed reading something not
necessarily philosophy what's going on
when you read now physically your
eyeballs are going back and forth and
stuff like that that's not particularly
fun right I mean I can do that just here
like that
that's not reading is it what's going on
when you read something yeah crazy taken
in what you're reading yeah those words
those those letters put together they
mean something that's mental that's
something of your soul
even if you read exports Illustrated
you're reading something that conveys
meaning right it's not purely at the
bottom you know sports even things like
purely the body
not completely what about friendships
when you have a friendship is that just
two bodies occupying the same place you
know or you know being next to each
other at the same time maybe engaging in
the same activities that make friendship
what makes friendship
well whoop what made you be friends
Hitler friends we help all of you good
friends having the same beliefs and
practice that's a big one yeah that's
mental right yeah well whose personality
is that you know they're not completely
solos they don't totally clash okay
you could add all sorts of other kinds
of relationships where they're not good
meshes but they they fit together well
that would be something you could carry
with you your friendships these guys are
thinking of cyber jesus died with souls
and pass on we're still going to have
some sort of sense of who the guy was
there's traces that are left there we're
more knowledge acquiring knowledge
itself this is we're gonna start getting
towards the doctrine of the recollection
of the forms
well the Philosopher's according to the
Plato
this is view philosophy it's not
actually one that myself I completely
endorse his view is philosophy is a
process of getting yourself away from
the body and focusing on the mental
spiritual the things that matter to the
soul and one of those things is absolute
reality try to figure out what really is
that's a good segue into looking at the
doctrine of recollection did you notice
any differences and the treatment here
compared to the meat
if you didn't that bouquet is all
pointing off here but if we did I'd be
interested to hear you notice any
differences between those two accounts
yeah kind of just touched upon it and
I'm new to it whereas here that he
specifically examples of why this to be
true very good that's one party that's
more specific now when I had you guys do
your paper on the doctrine of
recollection of the me know some of you
pointed out some real problems with it
you know what is Socrates saying
something like everything that we know
is recollection the Meno could be
interpreted that way couldn't it
Socrates clearly isn't saying that here
in theta there is some knowledge so now
it's some learning learning about how to
get around here at Marist it's now like
you were here at MERIS in a previous
life right you actually have learned
okay here's Fontaine Hall and over here
for your philosophy class and go to
Dyson curve with some nice business this
is the basis of Dyson through your
business classes and you go to Donnelly
for science classes that's all stuff you
didn't learn through recollection you
may remember it later on somebody may
remind you hey you got the logic that's
where do you need to go like all
philosophy that means Fontaine right
that's not the sort of recollection he's
talking about but the Meno kind of made
it sound like all knowledge fits into
that didn't it so maybe pointed that on
you're like I don't know by that
Socrates narrows it in here and he says
that it's about certain other things
like what he calls
absolute we have absolute things like
justice itself or equality perfect
equality or courage temperance things
like that
also things like beauty and what it
turns out that he's really talking about
or what are called the forms and so it
turns out that the doctrine of
recollection is tied in with this
doctrine of the forms what are the forms
well let me actually race this down so I
can use this let's use Beauty right
have you guys seen beautiful things what
are some some examples of beautiful
anything beautiful in this room okay
good example anything else
my wife clocked me into like getting a
nice wallet you know this is beautiful a
very different way than the Sun but you
look at it and it's a culture wall you
know I didn't realize it coach did so
many things that's nice leather and you
know good leather kind of wears in a
certain way it takes on a kind of Katina
and all that swatches of the Apple what
else is beautiful that you guys
experienced what do you find beautiful
hope there's lots of you yeah certain
landscape okay landscapes Wow we guess
by people beautiful hope so so here's a
otherwise you find your bait better be
attractive in their personality
recommends physical beauty at all what
else anything else we find beautiful but
music so any music that you guys like
not just because it's good to work out
too but you actually like when you're
not working out you listen to it why do
you like it if you you may not actually
find it necessarily beautiful you
wouldn't describe in that that term but
you have aesthetic terms that you would
use now notice all of these things on
this level they're all to some degree
their material examples there are things
that you can encounter face to face in
this world in this life right music how
do you guys encounter music sometimes
you encounter whether you want to a nap
somebody's over how do you actually a
cover though get on your mp3 player and
in play on your computer on your iPod
pick whatever you like maybe make your
own music if some of you play
instruments if you whistle
I sort of whistle compulsively but I
like to I like music a lot so if I'm
left on my own sooner or later I'll
start whistling sometimes it's beautiful
sometimes it's not but it's all
individual instances it's all things
that you can see smell touch here it's
all here in this material world right
now what about someone it's always not
really bottled here right unless you
want to be a scientist in its full times
during pinching upon our eyeballs all
that
but you can see it can't you oh yeah
feels good to doesn't actually hit a
certain amount or else your body's gonna
have a deficiency this wallet clearly
something tangible right landscapes you
experience landscapes don't you you look
at a landscape painting right you know -
in Geographic I look at a landscape it's
really great interest right landscape
things in Pinterest but is that does
that like being there better experience
doesn't it and then find the people oh
yeah look at a picture of somebody
actually it's kind of interesting too as
we a lot of people who look beautiful
let's just because we're good at
airbrushing their pictures you know HDTV
was kind of a a good thing at a bad
thing that wasn't it number one HDTV
came out first and you look at people
and you'd be like well I thought that
person was attractive now I realize
they're not because you can see all the
imperfections that leads us to the
second point about this person who's
attractive are they attractive all the
time here's here's one way to think
about it have you ever like seen photos
here's a great example if you take this
this video footage and you go slide by
slide by slide you know there's some
there's some times we're on taking a
position like this it's perfect I look
like I'm really teaching and then
there's other times when my idea like
laws like this or
I look like an idiot right why is it
well cuz I exist in time and we moved
from place to place and we you know
transition if I'm attractive at all you
know some people find me attractive at
least they all my wife right I'm
certainly not beauty itself and no human
being could be because any human being
put them on camera long enough you'll
find some shot where they look like a
complete doofus even if you like frozen
in time it's a weird kind of fetish
freeze people are you experiencing the
beauty of that person fully anymore no
landscape can a landscape turn from
beautiful to deadly kind of turn from
beautiful to ugly yeah my wallet how
many of you actually probably not too
many of you say wow that's really
attractive you know it depends on the
feel and I'm not going to in my wallet
offer you guys to feel you can look at
it you can't really see it close up so I
think it changes as well sunlight
sunlight is great when you're basking in
it when you're trying to cross the
mid-hudson bridge and it's shining right
in your eyes at 7:30 in the morning and
you're already not feeling too good so
it feels like a spike going into your
brain suddenly it's not so beautiful
listen you might even start cursing what
about music do you like the same music
all the time does that music always stay
beautiful for you yeah you there's there
some song that you will always enjoy
always love that's pretty good
is that the case we won't say all is
that the case with most of it I taste a
change you know I like 1987 metal
mayonnaise in 1970s and my you know my
wife complains is that mostly what I
play and she likes it but that's not her
entire range of musical tastes but
there's times where even I you know
don't want to listen to it and I want to
listen to something else instead or I
just want to quiet I don't want to hear
any music that's because these are not
absolute beauty if we actually
encountered absolute Beauty face-to-face
we would never want anything else it
remains the same unchanging all the time
and every instance of beauty that we
experience participates in some way in
that perfect form of beauty likewise
with justice or other virtues do you
know people who are just who are good
people they do the right thing at the
right time for the right reason some of
you maybe those people are they perfect
with just those people do they ever
screw up we have any weak points so does
everybody even if they they are does
everybody acknowledge that person as
perfectly just some people who like you
know the person was just and they don't
like that the person being just actually
took something away from them that they
like they'll call that person up just
won't pay in this world we never
encounter perfect justice
we never encounter perfect courage we
never encounter perfect temperance we
never encounter perfect wisdom right in
virtues but we do encounter our people
who have them to some degree or you know
to a lesser degree or not at all and
those virtues that those people have
participate in the form or the absolute
reality of that
what about equality have you ever seen
two things that are perfectly equal
think about geometric shapes you ever
seen a perfect sir
you can't they don't exist I mean you're
not gonna find another computer screen
because the computer screen is built of
pixels right we add those pixels are not
it's an approximation it's you know like
a little bit line here then it goes a
little bit like that a little bit like
this no more curve if I try to draw a
circle that's clearly not a perfect
circle right if I were to get you up
here with a do they still use a
protractor and compasses and stuff like
that in geometry classes you guys that's
kind of good so you remember the the
compass and you stick it on a paper and
you can make like a perfect circle right
is it perfect put in my new little
imperfections in it according to Plato
there would be some perfect circle
somewhere else not here in the world
that we experience but when you die when
your soul is removed from your body or
when you're actually just contemplating
these these pure forms or essences by
themselves with your soul getting away
from your body here in this life what
you're doing is you're actually
encountering those those forms that you
can't find in this material world you
can't find in this bodily world the only
way that they're available to you is
through the mind being on its own being
pure so if you're if you really like
that sort of thing and if you actually
saw these Plato says this is all you
would ever want if you really liked
those sorts of things you would have to
get away from your body wouldn't you
this brings us back to the original
point
why is death not a bad thing for
Socrates because that's what philosophy
has been aiming at doing stripping the
body away from the soul so the soul can
see realities as they truly are the very
reality is that recollection put you in
touch with when you are recalling
knowledge
that you've previously had in this this
disembodied life before it's not a you
know what did I eat last Wednesday or
how do you make a banana split or you
know what is the new iPhone coming out
or so but then it's not that kind of
knowledge it's not even necessarily
about language or something you brought
you know how do you speak a language or
things like that
it's about these fundamental realities
that's what the doctrine of recollection
really is focused on is these forms the
way that you can compare things as being
equal in this world is you saw the form
of equality at one time if you have a
kind of murky remembrance of that the
more that you work on it the less
merging more clear it'll get and that's
what the process of dialectic is this
process of working on it thinking about
it talking about it try to come up with
an account work that's what philosophy
according to Plato that's what it is so
what you're getting here is a picture of
the practice not everybody agrees with
this for you well just one thing is kind
of confusing a moment okay Plato
believes that saying the living life and
you actually learn something through
knowledge recollection of something that
your soul has learnt in the past yeah
but it's not connected to vehicle
physical body and is the sort of
repetition of the soul being bound by
body yeah if it's truly meeting true
knowledge why onto a body at all oh
that's a question that he addresses
perfect and the Philosopher's this gets
into some really mystical stuff at this
point philosophers has been thrice
purified
actually like gone and done study of
philosophy three times stripped
themselves away from the body as much as
possible remember the soul retains all
these through connections in life you
want to break that as much as possible
they don't they're not reincarnated
everybody else gives and so you've got a
body and soul and then the soul goes
away and sorry the bondage goes away and
the soul goes on here is wherever it's
supposed to be the soul it's it forms
again and then the soul goes back into
the body and you know it keeps on
flowing another fire what keeps the
process moving along he's got a couple
different like in I explained what
you're going to get punished for the bad
things did and purified but really what
that boils down to is that the soul has
taken on too much of the body and so
when it goes off by itself in this world
sees the forms it goes back to another
body because it's sort of drawn to two
bodies the soul wants to say get to eat
a hamburger you know we're going to be
really frozen
it wants to enjoy having sex again he
wants to enjoy laying in the Sun again
and just you know taking a nap it values
those things more than it values what's
available here which is wisdom
the more that you cultivate wisdom for
its own sake the more times you make
choices you have to make a lot of
choices in life wisdom or this other
thing that's that seems to be attractive
at the time right going out having sex
eating you know fancy food all those
sorts of things watching the game I
guess you know Socrates would probably
be watching a Super Bowl
and getting in some argument with
somebody you know about what is the
meaning of games or something like that
heyo in a way you could become a drag
this is not necessarily for everybody
matter of fact Socrates doesn't seem to
think this is for more than a few people
but if you are willing to sacrifice
everything to wisdom which is getting to
know these forms that eventually you'll
be free to this otherwise you're stuck
going round and round because you're
you're tying yourself but you know in
some respects it's kind of similar to
what you see in Buddhism and Hinduism is
it Those review of study world religions
the notion of Karma Socrates is bringing
out karma here but the notion of karma
is attaching the soul to new bodies same
idea
basically that's probably a good place
to leave loss or almost all the time
next class we'll consider the actual
arguments about the existences we didn't
get into those this class next class
will dig into them